after more than a year of controversy
since the start of the national anthem
I guess Fiasco is what I'm calling it
the NFL has now passed a new policy
which will require it will mandate that
all NFL football players on the field as
well as team personnel stand during the
national anthem and if you don't want to
stand you can be in the locker room
during the anthem but if you're on the
field and you don't stand you will be
fined by the leak the teams can also set
up their own fine structures in addition
to the league finds all NFL team owners
who voted approve this rule we know that
at least the San Francisco 49ers wear
this sort of started right with Colin
Kaepernick the 49ers abstained from
voting one way or the other and we don't
know how many teams in total abstain but
nobody voted against it and it's
actually more than just standing during
the anthem the rule as written now says
that players in personnel must show
respect to the anthem and and if you sit
or kneel
that's definitely disrespect but it
could conceivably extend to other
actions so let's break this down
question one very simple question can
the NFL do this is there anything
illegal about this absolutely not
it's an organization with a handbook and
one of the rules can be you got a stand
you can't sit nor kneel during the
anthem if you do you will be fined can
the players choose to ignore the rule
and be fined of course right they are
absolutely free to kneel if they want to
but with financial consequences which
they might decide are worth it to them
in order to make a point the problem
here is number one yet again we're
talking about either the criminalization
or in this case the penalization of
non-violent speech and what we call
nonviolent protests right yes the NFL
can say that the field which is sort of
like the office of sorts for the players
are is not the place for those types of
protests and I'm not arguing with that
of course they can do that and they did
but it is now yet another place where
you get in trouble for peacefully and in
this case silently taking politically
active actions and even their statement
that if you want to protest you can stay
off the field in the locker room
you're hiding the protest so that no one
notices them right if you're Tom Brady
and you're not on the field because
you're protesting the anthem
I guess people will notice on a team of
50 something football players if you're
a random second-stringer second string
or defensive back or something and you
remain in the locker room during the
anthem does anybody notice of course not
and that's the entire point right and
then lastly and this is a really complex
path to go down because the policy as
it's currently been described as you
can't disrespect the anthem which
includes sitting or kneeling what about
facing away from the flag right what if
you stand but you're the one person who
when you're about to have the national
anthem played takes two steps forward
and then turns your back to where the
flag is
is that disrespect you're not sitting
you're not kneeling you're on the field
and you're standing there silently but
you're facing the other way and if it
isn't respectful who decides right does
the league decide does the team decide
do other players decide or just Donald
Trump in a tweet decide what's
respectful so the NFL is obviously
completely within their legal rights to
do this and I'm totally against it and I
think it's horrible but I think that the
undertone here is one of total
subjectivity with regard to this respect
it is yet another one of these cases
where you're taking an act that started
right what started this whole thing
exposing racial inequality right
protesting racial inequality has
triggered a bunch of rich team owners to
say we're gonna make it more difficult
to do that so I think that this is
absolutely despicable one good guy in
all of this is the CEO of the New York
Jets
imagine me Pat a Patriots fan praising
the Jets Chris Johnson says that he's
going to pay the fees defines for any
players who want to protest on the field
saying I do not like imposing any club
specific rules if somebody on the Jets
takes a knee that fine will be borne by
the organization by me not the players I
never want to put restrictions on the
speech of our players do I prefer that
they stand of course but I understand if
they felt the need to protest there are
some big complicated issues that we're
all struggling with and our players are
on the front lines I don't want to come
down on them like a ton of bricks and I
won't there will be no club fines or
suspensions of any sort or any sort of
repercussions if the team gets fined
that's something I'll have to bear
that's the right answer
the New York Jets the guidepost on this
issue here coming from a Patriots fan I
think that this is an absolutely
despicable rule and I am not questioning
the NFL's right to do it but I think
this is absolutely horrible I think
it'll effectively end the kneeling
protest because you think it does have
to be out in public if it's in a locker
room no one's going to notice no one's
going to give any attention to it it's
like every speech zone it's exactly like
having a free speech zone I mean think
back to like you know the 1968 Olympics
where there was those two black runners
who came I think in first and third
place in their race yeah and they stayed
they stood there and they gave the Black
Power salute there was an image of that
it went all around the globe and that
was like an active form of protesting
yeah this kind of like what this was
like the same thing in a different way
like saying do that do that but in the
locker room John John Christophersen the
other guy do it do it in the locker room
if you want to do that that's totally
fine but you got to do it in the locker
room where there's no camera and
nobody's gonna notice it so I am
completely opposed to this but I am NOT
I want to be super clear the NFL can do
this and we can obviously decide whether
or not we want to keep watching football
or keep attending games or whatever the
case may be I am not convinced that this
is the end of the kneeling protests or
or at least let me put it a different
way I'm not convinced it's the end of
the anthem protests I just am not yet
sure sort of what form they will take
and I think that the turning your back
is an interesting one which at least
seems to stick to the letter of what the
new rule is